So for tasks number one.
We kind of did this in session one?
We must find the roots.
Of the constraint of the constraint functions or the
constraint equations.
To find a point outlining the feasible region.
So we have two constraints and both by the way in in LP
problems the objective function and
their constraints are all linear meaning they produce lines.
So we're not going to look at quadratic equations
every variable in the
lp all variables in the end. The lp problem
will have will be raised to the power one.
Not more than that.
Okay.
so
the first constraint is going to produce one line
the other conceptual produce another line and
then we need to
well find the region that does not.
Overlap into the other region you'll see exactly what
this means once we start plotting.
All right.
Now what we need to do is of course.
to solve this
you must explain the constraints which are currently inequalities.
And express them as equations.
So we have the following two equations.
So you can see.
and remember 200x
X is the number of
the premium containers
why is the variable corresponding to the standard containers?
So this is constraint one. This is
constraint to
in order to find the reason we have to solve for x and y
so first
now, of course we could put these two equations into a
matrix and then do
gaussian elimination
but this is only two equations so we can
just do something simple. So we have equation 1 and equation
two subtract them subtract first equation from the up the
one below and then we can simplify it to more.
So 200 minus 100 gives us 100 x
100 why my minus 100 y that
just gives us 0 y
now, of course this wouldn't appear in the equation, but I'm just putting it here.
So, you know that this is not eliminated.
And of course 4,000 minus 3,000 is 1,000.
So again, we're getting we're getting closer to finding
the most points of the feasible, which I only did this and I
know this is not precise, you know, we should keep the units of
measurement we should keep but but I did
that intentionally just to
because tuning out to me too many numbers.
I thought we simply but anyway, we'll keep this.
It's a good thing you brought it up.
We simplified. So right now we have to find what
x is equal to and what Y is equal to.
by
performing some classical algebra Elementary algebra.
So first we find X.
So y goes out of the picture.
And we divide 100.
We divide both sides of the equation by a 100 so I
can let me just simplify. It makes up think so that I
clear here.
This zero would go away.
And then we would have to get 100 to go on the other
side.
and then this of course if you want to keep
our scientific notation
okay, and then
I'm just gonna leave this out for now. Okay, because I'm gonna
I'm gonna confuse myself as well. But here
we know where we this implies that this is actually
100 times 10 to the power 4
Okay.
I'll leave a note here node.
here
10,000 is actually
times 10
power 4
Anyway X is equal to 10.
Quick comment here when we say 10. We
shouldn't forget that. This is 10 times.
10 to the power of 4
so X is actually equal to
100,000
so we found our first root.
now what we do is now that we know what x is we plug it in we plug
in x
for the other equation
so then we get
this bit
so we call this.
and then
solving four y
So what we have done here.
Is we've taken equation number.
that's 100 y so this equation to
equation 2
agent
so here
we have
3000 again here with this implies
that it's
you know.
30 million
and
let me just make sure I didn't leave anything out by mistake.
I think I did.
Yeah, I was supposed to bring this here.
So we take equation two.
We take the 10 this 10 over here.
Right. That's our root for X the value for the root
X.
And then we plug it in into equation too. So
this becomes 100 times 10.
Plus 100y equals 3,000 or actually
30 million.
And that's exactly what we've done here.
Okay again, just to be consistent with the notation.
I am going to
There we go. Like so
again, I don't want you to be too fixated on the
units of measurement or the scale the proportions.
I just want you to see that the idea here is we have
two inequalities to express them as equation and then we solve for
x and y to find a point that is the key thing here.
So we do some algebraic management manipulation right here. We
have 100 y. So in order to
move with this term to the right side,
we substrate we subtract it. So 100 times 10. That's
a thousand.
So now we get 3,000 from up here.
Minus 1,000 so it is
this move the right side of the equation.
Subtracting these two we get two thousand. All right, it's actually supposed
to be you know, 20 million.
And then we divide.
we divide 200 over 100 because
you know, this is where we're getting the 100 from right? It's this one.
this 100
will bring it we divide both sides by 100 and it
gives us 20.
So in other words the root for
X is 10.
And for why it's 20 which gives us this point.
Now what I want to show you.
is
Plotting part 1. So again, we have we have
done part 1 so far or should this task one, which
is finding the feasible region of the objective function.
So I'm going to switch to python out to show you how it's done
with python how we will use matplotlib to plot this.
And that will return to find the best point for the
objective function.
And that is the point.
In the feasible region that will maximize the profit.